l'équipe de coordinateur de parcours du
chu est toute récente
à peine deux ans elle se compose
uniquement de nicole ursule et omer
murté leur mission aider les patients
qui ont du mal à quitter l'hôpital soit
parce que le contexte est difficile
soit parce qu'aucun proches ne veut les
accompagner en moyenne ça concerne dix
patients par jour dont 3 qu'il visite à
domicile
il s'agit après la sortie de vérifier la
bonne prise en charge de ces patients
pour éviter qu'ils ne reviennent bloquer
des lits à l'hôpital
si ça n'est pas une vraie nécessité
aujourd'hui au maire et nicole vont
visiter alain 67 ans il souffre d'un
début d'alzheimer et samedi dernier et
s'était retrouvé à passer 24 heures aux
urgences sa famille n'était pas très
pressé de le retrouver
seul un frère et une soeur sont en
mesure d'aider alain au quotidien car la
fratrie a perdu deux frères récemment
dont il a aussi fallu s'occuper se
sortait à peine de mort et de l'eau et
c'est celui-là avec les crimes se
retrouver comme ça alors ça me fait une
chute change pas ce que je dois
travailler jeudi 10 heures de travail
assez régulière de 18h45 jusqu'à 5h30 et
c'est le mercredi que je le ton pour
faire mais ça fait il ne manque le
samedi il faut que j'en perds mon petit
frère ou soit lui soit moi au monde et
il faut faire avec le samedi et dimanche
il faut qu'on se on se relaie sa fatigue
ce sera sa fatigue alors là je me sens
abouti qu ils aient de quoi financer
jouer mais quand les classes parce que
nous sommes nous fatigues de fatigue
automatismes travaillés au final alain
est plutôt bien installé cet ancien
technicien de france télécom vit seule à
ducos et il garde encore un peu
d'autonomie et de vivacité d'esprit
ici c'est plutôt la prise en charge
médicale qui pêche est très vite
l'équipe de sortie complexe va proposer
plusieurs solutions et un accompagnement
à la soeur et danse familiale il
ad'autres votre audition de vie puisque
monsieur qui je pense orange à le
laisser ce week end je vois que les
mieux dans son environnement
j'ai déjà elle est déjà plus au nord il
paraît plus frais
moi moi moi je crois qu'en la matière il
a juste une éducation du match à
domicile a fait en bien mis et cailloux
maintien à domicile ou placement en
institution
la soeur épuisé dit vouloir placer alain
mais ce dernier souhaite rester chez lui
il est vrai que pour la famille la prise
en charge d'une personne âgée atteinte
qui plus est d'alzheimer est
particulièrement lourde et compliquée
encore plus quand la famille habite sur
fort de france quand elle est encore
actif professionnellement et quand le
patient habitat du cos comme c'est le
cas ici pour les dents ça peut être la
solution pratique mais pour le patient
ça parce qu'il l'a quand même demandé un
maintien il veut quand même resté dans
son environnement
donc ça peut être peut aboutir mais pas
brutalement
l'équipe constituée par nicole ursule et
et omer murté a pour principal objectif
d'éviter l'engorgement de l'hôpital par
des patients dit bête bloqueurs ou
bloqueur de lits mais elle a surtout une
mission humaine en favorisant et
améliorant le métier à domicile de ses
patients pour la plupart âgés de plus de
75 ans aujourd'hui il travaille de plus
en plus avec les mairies car il s'agit
souvent de personnes isolées ou vivant
dans le plus grand dénuement
de quoi nous faire tous réfléchir quand
on sait que nous serons sous peu le
territoire le plus vieux de france